let's check out some of the interesting
discussions on the David Pakman show
reddit the David Pakman show read it now
has we are within striking distance let
me put it that way of twenty thousand
subscribers one of the largest
progressive independent media subreddits
out there go to david pakman.com slash
read it to find it a user named dismal
structure posted some polling about how
well joe biden is doing in arizona
florida and georgia now while it is true
that there is one poll that has Biden up
one in Georgia but Biden is on average
down seven or eight points in Georgia
I don't consider Georgia a battleground
state I don't really consider it in play
but that could change Arizona and
Florida we've been talking about a lot
and are really really important signals
about how the November election could go
but I just want to reiterate I have no
problem looking at polls I have no
problem reporting on polls to you what I
am cautious of is I don't want anybody
to see a poll in their state that looks
good for Biden and to say Biden's got it
in the bag I don't need to vote so the
the reason I've only been talking about
these polls sparingly is I'm trying to
be responsible and avoid any action that
might suppress the vote by getting
someone to say I don't need to go out
there and vote so I will of course tell
you what the polling is looking like and
we've been doing it I appreciate it
being posted to the subreddit but we
should consider polling a possible
snapshot today in May and not
representative of what is certain to
happen in November and everybody's got
to go out and vote here's kind of a
funny post from Brody Mulligan Brody
says should we outlaw endless shrimp
endless pasta and free refills the
coronavirus disproportionately kills
people who are obese people who are
obese are more likely to partake in
endless shrimp endless pasta or free
refills we can use public health
justification to crack down should we
listen here's the thing I when I was
like nine I went to Ponderosa in
Northampton Massachusetts and would love
just going up to the buffet endlessly
when I was 17 I once went to a now Olive
Garden and they'll just keep bringing
your bread straight breadsticks if
that's what you want
it's obviously not
we know from looking at the work of food
psychologists that it encourages
overeating
it causes overeating I don't know if
Brody is literally serious about banning
and listen endless pasta but one of the
things I think we have to consider is
while I'm sure Brody's instincts are
coming from a very good place a lot of
these things will disproportionately hit
poorer people there's I would venture a
guess that folks more likely to
patronize places with a buffets or
unlimited this or that are
disproportionately likely to be folks
with less money and so in the same way
that I understand why we we might say 63
million people voted for Trump we need
some kind of a test in order to be
allowed to vote that's the type of stuff
that will disproportionately hit poor
people if it also when it comes to
voting I think would be unconstitutional
so I get the instinct Brody but I think
we may end up causing new problems if we
do that and we want to bear that in mind
lastly we talked about this on the bonus
show this week Donald Trump keeps saying
that there's a cost to staying closed
for example suicides would go up I've
not yet seen data from the United States
about that but what we know in Japan is
that suicides are actually down as the
lockdown has removed a lot of the
stressors associated with daily life we
know that commuting to jobs is one of
the most stressful and least pleasant
things for people to do we know that
work culture is a very stressful anxiety
causing thing for people to do and
suicides are down in Japan during the
lockdown now it's important to mention
the US isn't Japan Japan is
stereotypically known for a particularly
toxic work culture I'm not saying the
exact same thing would happen in the US
but when Trump offhandedly throws
something out as if it's an absolutely
foregone conclusion
suicides will be up if we're locked down
there are at least anecdotally Americans
who are actually better off because
they're preferring to work from home
they have eliminated a lot of the
cultural stresses of being at worked the
commuting etc it needs to be researched
and I'm sure you all know this Donis
assume that because Trump says something
it's necessarily true join the
discussion on the subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t